all right in today's morning rounds a
study in the journal of the American
Medical Association finds a link between
high blood pressure and dementia about
one in three American adults have high
blood pressure dr. Tara nurullah joins
us with what you can do to stay healthy
good morning doctor nice to see you what
is the connection to begin with so
dementia affects about 10 percent of
Americans over 65 we don't have a lot of
great treatments or preventive measures
and a lot of people don't know that
hypertension or high blood pressure can
be associated with future risk of
dementia and this is something that's
potentially modifiable and dementia
being one of the most feared conditions
for American adults so this particular
study looked at about 4,800 Americans
and followed them over 24 years and they
looked at blood pressure patterns and
they found two patterns that were
associated with an increased risk of
dementia the first was when you had high
blood pressure in mid life which is 50s
to 60s that persisted into your later
life the second pattern was if you had
high blood pressure in midlife but then
developed very low blood pressure in
your later years and by low I mean less
than 90 over 60 and so all of this
really again highlights the fact that
hypertension is potentially modifiable
we can really make a huge public health
impact by controlling this we need to be
starting this early in your 40s and 50s
and as far as the older population is
concerned we do need to kind of do more
research to figure out what is the ideal
blood pressure when you get older that
we should be targeting yeah what is the
answer to that and what can you do to
control your blood pressure well there's
a lot you can do and so first of all you
have to start getting screened early we
actually tell people in your 20s you
should start getting screened you should
know what your numbers are have that
very close relationship with your doctor
where if you do have high blood pressure
you're getting checked often if you're
prescribed medications please take them
every day as prescribed and then there
are a lot of lifestyle things you can do
so we talked about reducing salt in your
diet increasing potassium exercising
controlling your weight limiting alcohol
consumption quitting smoking so lots of
things that are in your hands to control
your partner you mentioned your doctor
monitoring blood pressure but you know
there are tests for at home I also see
in the drugstore they'll have that
little thing you put your arm in are
those reliable they can be you know we
do prescribe those or tell our patients
to use those because they help us
monitor how well
they're being controlled at home or what
their pressure is at home cuz for a lot
of people when they come to the doctor's
office for example their pressure is
very high they're nervous are anxious
and then at home it's a little bit lower
and also if you're on treatment it gives
us a sense of how well you're being
treated so one thing you can do is you
know get a get a monitor even bring it
in to your doctor's office and compare
it with the pressure they're getting in
the office to see how accurate why is
why is high blood pressure tower
considered a silent killer this is such
an important point you know high blood
pressure is asymptomatic for a lot of
people you feel well and so you think I
don't really have high blood pressure or
maybe I had it one time but now I'm fine
I don't need to take my medications but
what it's doing is it's damaging it that
increased pressure is damaging all the
blood vessels that supply blood
throughout your body and this is why
it's associated with an increased risk
of chronic kidney disease stroke heart
attack heart failure vision loss
sexual dysfunction I mean anywhere
there's an artery in your body that's
seeing high pressure there's potential
to damage those cells all right Terry
you've inspired me to get tested and
find out what my number is thank you
very much we appreciate it